Aquí tenemos una función cuadrática
y nosotros ya sabemos que una función cuadrática cuando la gráficamos se ve como una parábola.
Ahora si yo quisiera encontrar las raíces y el vértice de esta parábola,
bueno podríamos tratar de manipular esta expresión que tengo aquí, para encontrarlas de una manera mucho más sencilla.
Y quiero que en este momento tú pauses el vídeo e intentes por ti mismo trabajar con esta función que tengo aquí, para encontrar tanto el vértice como sus
raíces. La intersección con el eje de las "x" y así podemos ver de una manera muy sencilla, cómo podemos graficar esta función
cuadrática que tengo aquí.
Muy bien ahora vamos a intentar resolverlo y vamos a ver a qué llegaste. Lo primero que quiero es encontrar las raíces,
así que para encontrar las raíces
lo que necesito es que esta expresión se haga 0, es decir lo que estoy buscando
es que "x" cuadrada -5x más 6
sea igual a 0 y con esto voy a ver en dónde
interceptamos al eje de las "x". Así que si aquí tenemos
al eje "x" vamos a suponer que este es lo que voy a encontrar, es donde interceptamos al eje "x"
igualándola a 0 por que lo que estoy haciendo es que "y" es decir f de "x" sea igual a 0. Por lo tanto no vamos a tener
ninguna altura ¿Ok? Y como queremos la gráfica de una vez dibujo aquí ambos
ejes. Este es le eje de las "y". Ahora si yo quiero que esta expresión se haga 0,
entonces puedo encontrar la solución de esta ecuación, si yo
hago la fórmula general de segundo grado o si factorizo esta expresión y yo prefiero factorizar esta expresión, así que vamos a buscar
2 números, a 2 números cuyo producto sea 6, cuya multiplicación sea 6 y déjame ponerlo así,
Cuyo producto sea 6 y cuya suma o bueno en este caso cuya resta,
cuya suma sea 5. Lo voy a poner así, cuya
suma sea 5. Ahora si yo tengo 2 números cuyo producto es 6
entonces, o ambos son positivos o ambos son negativos pero, como la suma tiene que ser negativa entonces, deben de ser ambos negativos.
Voy a buscar 2 números negativos que su producto me de 6 y bueno 6 por 1
es 6 pero su suma no me da -5, no, no.
Por que uno sería negativo y el otro también, me daría -7, y 3 por 2, 3 por 2
producto me da 6, -3 por -2 y su suma me da -5
por lo tanto ya está, los dos que quiero son ¡Ah! Me los voy a poner aquí, -2 y -3 así que puedo
reescribir esta ecuación de la siguiente manera, puedo decir que esto es  exactamente lo mismo que tomarme "x"- 2
Ok déjame ponerlo con el mismo color que a su vez multiplica a "x" -3
que a su vezmultiplica a "x" -3 y esto tiene que ser igual a 0.
Esto quiero que sea igual a 0 y bueno si 2 números
multiplicándose son igual a 0 eso quiere decir, o que el primer es 0 o que "x" -2 es igual a cero,
o en su dado caso que el segundo es 0 "x" -3 es igual a 0,
y si de aquí sumo 2 de ambos lados de esta ecuación, voy a obtener que "x" es igual a 2.
Esta es una de las raíces o esta es una de las soluciones de esta ecuación
cuadrática que tengo aquí, y aquí si sumo 3 de ambos lados de esta ecuación voy a obtener
que "x" es igual a 3. Esta es la otra raíz o
puedo decir que esta es la otra de las soluciones de esta ecuación cuadrática que tengo aquí.
"x" igual a 2 o "x" igual a  3 y ya los puedo poner justo en esta gráfica.
Como estoy buscando las raíces, lo que estoy buscando es la intersección con el eje de las "x" de mi función
cuadrática, que por cierto yo sé que es una parábola lo que no sé, es si es una parábola que abre hacia arriba o hacia abajo.
Al menos ya sé por donde pasa en el eje de las "x", vamos a ponerlo 1,
2,
3 ¿Ok? Y mis raíces
están en 2, en 2 ¿Ok? Y en 3¿Ok? Ya sabemos que por aquí pasa mi parábola.
Ahora lo que quiero encontrar es el vértice ,ahora lo que vamos es a encontrar el vértice.
Vértice y para eso lo que voy a hacer es reescribir esta función que tengo aquí pero,
completando el binomio al cuadrado perfecto es decir, me voy a fijar en esto que tengo aquí arriba que es f de "x"
f de "x" igual a "x" cuadrada a "x" cuadrada -5x.
Y aquí hasta acá voy a poner el 6 por que lo que quiero es
fijarme en estos 2 y completar el binomio al cuadrado perfecto. Voy a fijarme en estos 2 para que sea un trinomio al cuadrado perfecto.
¿Ok? Entonces va a llegar hasta acá y lo que quiero es que,
estos 2 más otro tercero me den un trinomio cuadrado perfecto, para eso date cuenta que ya tengo el cuadrado del primero.
Aquí está 2 veces el primero por el segundo, y ahora requiero encontrar el cuadrado del
segundo y para eso lo que necesito es fijarme en el coeficiente que está al lado de la "x"
siempre, y a éste lo divido entre 2 es decir, que el valor que está aquí es más el
cuadrado y déjame ponerlo con otro color. Va a ser más el
cuadrado de
- 5 entre 2 es decir a -5,
5 entre 2 negativo esto lo voy a elevar al
cuadrado y bueno tú puedes corroborar que éste realmente es un trinomio cuadrado perfecto.
Ahora sí esta expresión de aquí, esta expresión de aquí que por cierto me da
25 entre 4
25 entre 4 lo estoy sumando la estoy agregando,
entonces lo que necesito es también quitarla, recuerda que para que se cumpla
esta función, esta igualdad, ya la estoy alterando al sumarle
esta expresión que tengo aquí, y por lo tanto puedo sumar de ambos lados esta expresión -5 entre 2 al cuadrado o dicho de otra manera,
lo que voy a hacer es quitar voy a quitar a
- 5 a -5 entre
2 elevado al cuadrado para que la función se mantenga igual. No pasó nada y lo único que hice fue
aquí completar un trinomio al cuadrado perfecto, por que ahora sí puedo decir que esta expresión que tengo aquí y déjame cambiar de color.
Esta expresión que tengo aquí es lo mismo que "x" -5/2
elevado al cuadrado
¿Ok?
Y bueno si no me crees o si te hace un poco difícil ver qué esto de aqui es exactamente lo mismo que esto de aquí,
tú podrías corroborarlo
elevando esto al cuadrado o repasando mis vídeos acerca de cómo completar un trinomio cuadrado perfecto, y bueno aquí tengo
f de "x" ¿Ok? Esto es igual a esto de aquí y después le tengo que sumar 6 ¿Ok? Sumar 6 y quitar a
- 5 al cuadrado es 25
25 sobre 2 al cuadrado es 4 ok, que por cierto 6 -25 entre 4 es lo mismo que 24/4
-25 /4 todo esto, todo esto es lo mismo que
- 1/4, - 1/4 entonces déjame ponerlo aquí. ¡Oh! Esto no parece 4, - un 1/4.
Entonces ahora si ya pude escribir a f de "x" de la siguiente manera.
f de "x" ahora lo puedo ver ya que complete el trinomio al cuadrado perfecto como
"x" -5/2  esto elevado al cuadrado y -1/4 , lo voy a poner con otro color
con este de aquí, -1/4
¿Ok? Ahora date cuenta que esta expresión de aquí,
es exactamente lo mismo que esta expresión de aquí, que es exactamente lo mismo que esta expresión con la que empecé y además quiero que veas
que lo estoy escribiendo de la siguiente manera, por que aquí tengo un binomio el cuadrado perfecto
y esta expresión que tengo aquí en rojo siempre es mayor o igual
que 0. Esta expresión siempre es mayor o igual que 0 por que si yo tengo
un cierto número sea positivo, o negativo y lo elevó al cuadrado me da un número positivo y la única forma en que
la expresión se haga 0 es cuando la parte de adentro se hace 0.
Ahora estoy diciendo que el valor más pequeño que puede tomar f de "x" escrito de esta manera, es que esto se haga 0, esto se cancele,
solamente me quede con -1/4  y con esto estoy corroborando que es
el punto más pequeño que puede tomar f
de "x" por que cualquier otro punto
va a ser que esto sea mayor o igual que 0 y entonces, algo mayor o igual que 0 cuando le sume -1/4
me va a dar algo más grande que -1/4,  así que lo que quiero es que "x"
- 5/2  esta parte de acá adentro, sea igual a 0 para encontrar el punto mínimo
sea igual a 0, y por lo tanto de aquí poder despejar a "x" y decir que "x" igual a 5/2
hacen que esta parábola o esta función cuadrática me dé un valor mínimo.
Ahora si "x" es igual a 5/2 de una manera muy sencilla puedo encontrar el valor de "y"
que está en el vértice, es decir en el punto mínimo y como lo puedo encontrar
bueno puedes sustituir este valor de 5 /2 aquí o aquí pero para no complicarme la vida mejor
lo voy a sustituir en la expresión donde es más fácil.
Encontrar a "y" que es justo esta, si yo pongo aquí 5/2, me quedaría 5/2 -cinco 5/2  lo cual es 0
0 al cuadrado es 0 y solamente me quedaría con - 1/4 que tiene todo el sentido lógico
del mundo, habíamos dicho que "y" igual a -1/4 era el valor más pequeño que podía tomar "y",
por que esto siempre es mayor o igual que 0.
Ahora aquí tengo ya otro punto, cuando "x" es igual a 5/2,  que 5/2 es lo mismo que 2.5
1,2.5 y déjame ponerlo con color rojo ¿Ok? Puede ser más o menos por aquí, me voy a fijar en que "y"
tome un valor de -1/4,de -1/4  y para eso
supongamos que aquí tengo a "y" igual a uno y 1/4 estaría como por aquí, así que me voy a fijar como por aquí y
donde se intersectan en este punto aquí estoy parado en el punto 5/2
déjame cambiar de color en el punto 5/2 ¿Ok? coma -1/4 coma
- 1/4 y ya puedo asegurar que como este es el punto mínimo que toma mi parábola,
entonces este es el punto de mi
vértice. Ya tengo una parábola que abre hacia arriba y cuyo vértice es este punto de aquí, es este punto de aquí.
Así que es hora de dibujarlo creo que ya me siento bastante
seguro para dibujar esta parábola y lo que voy a hacer es fijarme en la parábola que abra hacia arriba,
que toque este punto, cruce aquí al eje de las "x", toque este punto y después toque este punto y suba.
Más o menos así se va a ver un esbozo de mi parábola que
represente justo a la función con la que empecé, es decir a la función "x" cuadrada - 5x más 6.
Este es un esbozo de esa parábola y bueno
recapitulando, todo esto salió de tomarme la misma expresión solamente que vista de maneras distintas. En un primer lugar
factorice esta expresión y la iguale a 0 para encontrar las raíces
¿Ok? Y en un segundo lugar para encontrar el vértice lo que hice fue completar el trinomio cuadrado perfecto,
después aquí no olvide que esto es una
ecuación y por lo tanto si sumo aquí el cuadrado del segundo, aquí lo tengo que restar y después me fijé que
esto aparte,
siempre era mayor o igual que 0 y por lo tanto para hacerla 0 iguale la parte de adentro a 0, y me di
cuenta que el valor de "y" debe de ser igual a -1/4 y ya está.